oh hi news oh oh hi oh hi oh hi oh hi
mark day you submitted by a bacon
deodorant oh my god
for my disaster artist yeah Ohama no
from the room it's actually from a
student found a man hiding in her closet
and wearing her clothes did he look good
in it though I don't have photos I'd be
so pissed of him in her clothes did she
read him out of 10 this guy was wearing
my clothes yesterday I couldn't notice
his legs so small but is that so big
yeah you got the old ass he was wearing
your clothes yesterday which pan just
passed my barbell pins I didn't know cuz
her mom put her pants in my section cuz
I guess she didn't she thought they were
my pants but then we all have the same
set and then I just put my so I just
grab and I put my backpack when I took
the shower thoughts I put her mom that
daddies are freaking tight well there's
like gender-neutral pants though yeah
yeah there's Swiss cheese me and Joe
trade the barbel sweats that you guys
enjoy yeah we were the same size medium
she has a big ass you just have some
little girl legs though yeah he does get
a little girl egg it's cute are you
jealous
yeah I am your little knees they're so
cute cute knees there hold on guys cab
yeah and they're like little me they
really I have slender calves she's
trying to make you some bad guys she's
she's trying no there's a fight he's
other good in the broth I see
if I shave my legs and wore some heels
you guys would want to [ __ ] yeah and
then your heads oh my gosh yeah that's
true yeah you had the same hands
no more feminine than mine even better
are you kidding better pull up your
trucker hands yes because my fingers are
short
that's like me your hands are more
feminine than mine because you have long
slender fingers thank you
yes would look good on it you gave it
ain't nothing wrong with being gay
that's right mmm cuz I'm happy every day
okay [ __ ] all right so we're talking
about this dude here in the closet right
we're still on track
yes stabbed no [ __ ] surprisingly oh no
female students who attends the
University of North Carolina at
Greensboro was so scared when she found
this dude in her closet yeah she said
that she had been having pieces missing
like shorts and pants and all these
things and so she doesn't remove it as
well and they they found handprints on
the bathroom wall and a mirror at one
point and so they started thinking like
what the hell this is crazy
maybe we have ghosts what first thing as
ghosts
not like a drunk roommate or something
like more like the obvious like someone
broke into our [ __ ] yeah well I would
first think my roommates been [ __ ]
somebody here you know what's
interesting that they went to that
conclusion when in the past they have
found that two men were inside their
living room wearing ski masks and
they're like are you go believe there
was someone in my house this is the
fifth time like we can't call that one
one cuz they're ghosts
back then when they found those two men
in their living room the leasing office
they confirmed that they had changed the
locks to the apartment after that and so
they didn't file a police report or
anything so then now what you find two
guys in your apartment randomly and what
are they doing having coffee and [ __ ]
like my bad Rock house they don't tell
me what they were doing don't like
[ __ ] sitting there having a long
discussion yeah yes so many props in
that year there's literally so many
props it's 2d object hey don't call out
the artist let me let me do up let me
let me get it to my character okay grant
inter character yes hey what are you
doing in my house
excuse me we're having a conversation oh
sorry
don't worry I'm not gonna file a police
report just a mess because yeah watch
the company sink when you're ready to
leave thank you
so I was saying the homework on for
yesterday was [ __ ] crazy
that must be how long yeah that's
probably how it went down boy that was
great
yeah great work and scene thank you very
much my Oscar so white they need if I
can give me Oscar production from by Joe
Malin theater
all right so anyways don't you love it
you just moved in with them yeah I
[Laughter]
[ __ ] I can't see anything
I was like this I think she moved my
hair like this and in a way haha he did
the movie theater yeah yeah yeah it's
like it was like this instead of like
this yeah cuz my arms too short
yeah oh my god just stop with your poppy
carbs or too feminine do yoga no no it's
more like a t-rex oh yeah thank you
okay I'm trying to tell you guys the
rest of the story yeah okay so she hears
rattling in her closet she thought it
was a raccoon but they're so [ __ ]
left-field first thought was it ghost
man I thought well for surely it's
Dracula I think this girl's were later
Josh what's the craziest brainstorms in
the world she's like who's there and
then someone hands her a book and
raccoon is gonna be like it's just me
mr. raccoon just start speaking up the
garlic must be a Filipino person in the
back but it turns out that this dude was
like oh my name is Drew and he was in
there sorry it's just me yeah yeah
that's good so you was in there wearing
all of her clothes her socks her shoes
what a [ __ ] weirdo book bag full of
her clothes
it's he was gonna steal it
oh that guy's weird look just stay put
for a second I got the craziest coma
yeah dude how do you have such long hair
in your balls we have a sleeveless Gyan
no he's wearing heard like he was
wearing all her clothes but I can't tell
if these are her clothes looks like it
gives a little cap sleeve how did they
pose he's just ashamed the van I think
he was not violent huh
she had enough time to [ __ ] take a
picture of oh yeah she had time to take
a picture to keep him talking in the
meantime the police came and arrested
him so he was identified as a 30 year
old named Andrew he's 30 and he's that
bald hey you take it easy gonna be you
in a few years a few years oh my god
Steve if I'm [ __ ] lucky
no I don't I just go up the thing is he
has that long boyish like haircut too
yeah but then it's still Logan Paul yeah
it's the Logan Paul but it's he doesn't
have much to work with
yeah but it looks good they're kinda and
his face looks riddled with math man
yeah that's a face of a man oh well that
girl Maddie she was I can't wait to hear
that cuz the conclusion was how long do
you think he was living in there for no
so she couldn't sleep in her room so she
started sleeping in her roommates room
and so now they're gonna move out oh
thank god I mean the guys in jail right
was he breaking in but that's the second
time she got broken into in that play
like they need to get the [ __ ] out of
there there's obviously more to this
story but I don't know what else there
is but they don't tell me that he's
under a 26 thousand dollar bond he faces
14 felony charges including larceny and
identity theft 14 yeah for every piece
of clothing that he picked I know I
don't know maybe there's other charges
that you know yes I'm saying like
there's more to this I I wonder if the
two guys that were that they found in
their living room is like one of them
like he was one of us yeah if he was one
of the two guys pretty sure she would
have recognized him though there's just
a lot of people breaking in and out of
their house huh
I mean they must not leave their doors
long no no she said like they always
keep their doors locked and they didn't
notice any damage so they have no idea
how he got here maybe the job
Keitha oh I thought I saw because I read
this one before I thought I saw the the
cops say that there they found an
unlocked window oh I've been climbing
through the window we live on the first
floor and they leave the window open all
the time probably I mean bunny they
probably have a sliding door in the
[ __ ] they have it wide open
this article doesn't say anything about
a window I don't know a part of me is
just like I want to blame the victim but
they seem kind of stupid
I blame drugs well I mean that's always
the bottom of it but also that Maddie's
taking drugs so she sees ghosts she
comes up with the crazy but now the guy
I don't think think he was like wanting
to be a girl or anything I think he's
just fun crazy person oh yeah he did so
much drugs that he thought that was his
house he thought he was at the mall
shopping yeah right who knows
come on shopping he was in a dream world
he was an elegant woman shopping for a
dinner date and he was there for a few
days right more than one he's a lot
overnight he putts up you [ __ ] on a shoe
or something
he's realize that she was missing
clothes so I don't know like he was
gumming coming in and you know what I
noticed I only have like three right
socks I don't know where the left socks
are what do you think's been in art I
think you just walk around like barefoot
and you lose a sock and you just keep
going you know wait your socks that
right and left on them they're not just
either side no I look they have the art
and to have that element like the
aesthetic soft form like the same
thought if that I'm like oh boy like she
labels the socks the left one for the
right one or whatever it is that you're
missing you Kings the other one punching
holes into his mind right now don't
you're really wrecking - [ __ ] - he's I
could I could make one inside out and
then that will be the left one no cuz
it's actually like crazy
arch doesn't have any socks like that
I'm just some of them are I'm gonna be
honest I don't know you don't know imma
bring R and L on them get your customers
together
I'll do it I'll prove the world yeah cuz
I know I got it in France you gotta
clear your [ __ ] good name yep
I never lie those must be the socks that
are in the back of the drawer
she's right diets it doesn't say our
don't leave it in the back you have
those socks
[Music]